بدات رئيسه تايوان
رحله الى امريكا اللاتينيه تتوقف خلالها
في الولايات المتحده في طريق
ذهابها وايابها وتلتقي مشرعين امريكيين
وحذرت الصين التي تعتبر تايوان جزءا من
اراضيها من هذا التوقف في الاراضي
الامريكيه وقالت ان هذا الامر يعد
استفزازا لبيجين وقال المكتب الحكومي
الصيني لشؤون تايوان ان الامر يلحق الضرر
بسياده الصين ووحده اراضيها ويقوض السلام
والاستقرار في مضيق تايوان كما حذر من ان
الصين ستتخذ اجراءات للرد بشكل حازم وحث
واشنطن على عدم اجراء اي اتصال رسمي
برئيسه تايوان
بدورها اعربه المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه
الصينيه عن معارضه بلادها الشديده لاي شكل
من اشكال التبادلات الرسميه بين الولايات
المتحده وتايوان مؤكده ان بيجين ترفض
زياره الرئيس التايوانيه
للولايات المتحده تحت اي ظرف
نعرض بشده اي شكل من اشكال الاتصال الرسمي
بين الولايات المتحده والتايوان كما نعرض
بشده زياره مسؤولين تايوانيين الى
الولايات المتحده تحت اي ظرف او سبب نعرض
بشده انتهاك الولايات المتحده لمبدا الصين
واحده الصين قدمت احتجاجات رسميه لجانب
الامريكي في مناسبات عده بشان زياره
المتحده
وقبيله توجهها في رحلتها الى غواتيمالا
وبليز كانت رئيسه تايوان قالت ان الضغوط
الخارجيه لن توقف عزم بلادها على التواصل
مع العالم
ومن نحن هادئون وواثقون من انفسنا ولن
نستسلم ولن نستفز ستسير تايوان بحزم في
طريق الحريه والديمقراطيه وستنفتح على
العالم وعلى الرغم من ان هذا المسار صعب
لكن تايوان ليست وحدها